die grundlage für diesen film ist ein
roman und löschen von jeff van der meer
der hat drei romane gesprächen die in
dieser durchgedrehten weltspielen saljic
trilogie heißt das ding und das schöne
ist dieser erste band ist eigentlich
komplett und film war es gibt darin zum
beispiel im turm der gleichzeitigen
tunnel ist das kann man natürlich nicht
bebildern
es wird gesagt dass diese grenze
zwischen unserer normalen welt der rrx
nicht zu sehen ist was natürlich scheiße
ist wenn was nicht zu sehen ist und will
sprich das geht eigentlich nicht daraus
einen film zu machen aber das ist mir
sehr sehr gut
sie schicken drohnen truppen einmal
nichts kommen zurück das stimmt nicht
ganz
eine sache möchte ich als gewissens
übung besonders hervorheben nämlich
natalie portman weil ich habe über die
besetzten schlechtes gedacht gesagt und
geschrieben und das muss ich das alles
zurücknehmen weil ich habe nie
verstanden wie diese schauspieler
funktioniert was das soll weil für mich
war das immer so eine gespannte kabel
figur sonne immer leicht gereizte
personen die irgendwie gar keine lust
hat das zu machen was sie da macht und
jetzt verstehe ich was diese gespannte
saite was dieses gespannte kabel soll da
kann man nämlich musik drauf machen also
in diesem film ist dieses bis zum
zerreißen gespannte dieses angestrengte
von ihnen nicht nur großartig sondern
dann wenn sie es locker dann ist das ein
aufseufzen bedingten film und das
science fiction film versteht man ja
eigentlich sachen die die physik über
alles stellen also man denkt an
weltraumgeschichte man denkt ein
computer geschichten an sowas das
sozusagen materie in dem sinn von
elementarteilchen bis sagen wir mal
großraum und gravitation und sonnen und
so behandelt nur gibt es in der science
fiction schon immer so ein subgenre was
sich irgendwie mit biologie beschäftigt
was aber so ein bisschen an den rand
gedrängt ist von diesen spektakulären
sachen und in den letzten jahren dass
das interessante zeigt sich dass diese
art von bio fantasie eben auch für
kinder geeignet ist zum beispiel die
beiden letzten filme von ridley scott
die beiden letzten alien -filme promise
und covern machen daraus was aber ich
habe bis jetzt keinen film gesehen der
es so konsequent durchzieht wie dieser
film
das krokodil hat szene unmöglich
verschiedene spezies lassen sich nicht
kreuzen alex garland der tatsächlich
auch sowieso einer der interessantesten
leute ist im science fiction kino nicht
nur als regisseur mit ex machina wird in
thüringen test spannend verfilmt hat was
gar nicht so einfach ist sondern auch
als drehbuchautor fred days later oder
sunshine und solche sachen das heißt der
mann wird immer wichtiger immer besser
und ich würde sagen zusammen mit
villeneuve der jetzt den bachelor
gemacht hat den letzten und level
gemacht hat und mit kängurus der
abstellkammer gemacht hat ist er einer
der drei besten so wie früher die drei
besten kowski kubrick und sagen wir dass
gott waren in dem genre das ist durch
den st
durch den zaun in diesem film geht es um
das leben und zwar nicht in dem sinne
wie sozusagen shirley mclane filme vom
leben handeln nämlich ich habe meine
mutter lange nicht mehr angerufen
sondern das leben im sinne von das was
blutet das was stinkt dass sich vermehrt
usw
das heißt angucken sollten alle leute
die leben
[Musik]
er schafft etwas neues